what did we have a look at in these
style questions we had a look at this
process called differentiation right
when you differentiate something you
take a function like the three that we
had a look at and if your function is
called for example f of X what do we
usually call the result what name do we
give it a shot
F dash X perfect right this is what we
call the result from differentiation
okay depending on what you start with if
it's labeled differently we end up with
a slightly different label over here if
we if I said y equals what would you
call them this result you could call it
Y - should be using the same notation as
here but there's another way we can say
it as well dy and DX and it's not like
these one is better than the other
they're just different okay
but what's helpful is that each one sort
of communicates something a little bit
different underneath both of these
they're both massive abbreviations
because mathematicians famously lazy we
don't want to write the whole thing
that's behind here cuz it takes forever
see if you remember let me start you off
this is how the real thing begins
there's limb which stands for what limit
right what's the thing that's underneath
it
it's mmm so close it's another letter
it's an H and it's approaching zero
we'll come back to that a second and
then there's this monstrous fraction
here see if you can help me remember
I'll give you a start
F very close X plus h right there is a
minus sign there it comes in next minus
f of X and then what's on the
denominator H its H okay now we have a
name for this thing this is called first
principles very good and you can see why
we don't like writing it over and over
again because it takes a long time but
it captures something very important
number one what you're going to get out
of this is a function it's got all kinds
of function notation in there right but
number two the thing in this like this
fraction it comes from color it comes
from comparing rise over run yeah rise
over run so this thing here that dy Y is
a vertical thing that's what mean by
rise change in Y change in X is
okay so this whole process of
differentiation it tells us something
about gradient right so we have our
names here you start with some function
you get the derivative or we might call
that if we wanted to emphasize the fact
that it tells you about gradient we call
it the gradient function okay so you're
happy with this do you remember this
this is not I mean it's not been a while
it's been a while since we look at a
look at this but it's not brand-new
stuff right okay now what we have you
think about today is taking this process
differentiation and viewing it in
another color viewing it from the
opposite direction okay what if instead
of starting with this guy over here and
then going through this process right
what if we started from the other side
what if for example I gave you a
derivative right and I said hey what was
the function that came from
what is the function that it came from
now this is the opposite of
differentiation right so one of the
names for this process very very
unoriginal but probably the most
relevant one here is an T
differentiation
I know rocket science right okay we are
we are not differentiating we are
anti-differentiating okay now say again
this is a proper term because it is
exactly what we're being described here
now we'll come to other language this is
you know when we whenever we introduce a
new idea right you get lot a new
language that comes with it okay I'm
very deliberately number one not telling
you all of the language all in one hip
number two the language that I am going
to introduce I'm not going to fully
explain it either it's like the first
scene in a movie you're like who's this
character why they're doing that why
they angry these all emerge as the movie
progresses same deal here okay now I
just said what happens if I give you a
thing I tell you it's a derivative and I
want to know where it came from
okay well we would say you go from the
riveted to its original function but
what if the thing I hand you is not a
of any kind what if it's just any old
function what would we call the thing
that it came from now we have another
name for this it's like derivative but
the opposite I mean it's a word we often
associate with like evolution we say the
thing that it came from is the primitive
like a like primitive or prehistoric
humans that kind of thing right so it's
like where did you come from this is
where it came from okay
now as you can see here asked
mathematicians we try to avoid writing
long words where we can write so I'm now
going to lay on you
the notation around this but I'm going
to tell you right now it's weird and
confusing it asks more questions than it
answers okay so we're going to tease the
fact that I'm going to get to these
answers later but I want you to have the
notation so you don't have to keep
lighting long words okay so if you have
some function you remember right we
introduced this notation here to
indicate the opposite right this is just
a stretched-out
s you see the original function appear
and then we throw in this notation where
do we see this earlier it's on the board
already through differentiation right
now what's that tell you it tells you
differentiate and pay attention to the
X's you don't have to pay attention to
X's if your function is to do with
something else
like T for time or pay for population
you would pay attention to that but
that's what this is referring to here
okay
now this guy here this result here this
is the primitive that we're after the
ever question actually you just
scratching head okay right so this is
actually you can make a heading now this
is actually what we're going to focus on
yes
we'll come to it I'm just telling you
it's any other guess for now this is
what we're focusing on the primitive
function okay now you have to be really
really careful with this idea of
anti-differentiation and I'm going to
illustrate to you why you know
everything you need to know to do entry
differentiation to find primitives okay
you know everything you need but that
doesn't mean you know how to do it and
I'm gonna give you an illustration of it
at the top of your page right now and I
have to do this on a piece of paper not
on the whiteboard you'll see why in a
second I'm gonna ask you to do something
and I'm gonna ask you to do it
immediately without overthinking it too
much okay so I know you could take a
long time to do this I deliberately
don't want you to I just want you to
give it your best shot in about I'm
gonna give you at ten seconds to do it
okay I want you to take your name right
not my name but this is what I'm gonna
write I want you to take your name and
your whole name yes and on your page I
want you to do your very best to write
it upside down go ahead do it now write
it upside down okay go ahead and write
your name upside down okay like I said
I'll give you about ten seconds
some of you will find this easier than
others based on your name
some people what's your surname by the
way if you do if you did it upper case
that was slightly cheating because so
much easier an upper case okay all right
now what I want you to do is and lower
cases it's the way we real people do it
okay I want you to have a look at your
complete name
I just just look at it upside down for
me now just have a look at it the way
it's meant to be read how did you go
dude okay did it did your SS go
backwards or your what letters did you
get you didn't write your letters in the
correct order okay nice okay all right
now who's proud of their result by the
way who's like yes I nailed it okay good
now here's the theme right to go through
this process of anti-differentiation to
get a primitive okay you know everything
you need to know but because it's weird
and sort of upside down II okay you'll
end up doing things wrong just because
your brain is so used to doing it the
other way right this way right
so let's have a look at a quick example
and start to point out some of the
challenges here